deep beneath the ocean surface live vast
areas of seabed that have never before
been explored by humankind this is
camera control can we drop our speed to
one knot please
now state-of-the-art technology is
giving these scientists an unprecedented
opportunity take it down to the bottom
to conduct research that is vital to
protecting the ocean I just want to get
a little bit closer and to uncovering
the true nature of damage being done to
it but it really is incredible isn't it
[Music]
this is the RV investigator the ship
used by the Australian government and
marine scientists to research the deep
ocean off the coast of Tasmania a team
of scientists is on a remarkable mission
to investigate marine life thousands of
metres below the surface we're in a
harsh saltwater environment we're going
very deep so a very robust pressure
housings to keep the saltwater out
seawater and electronics don't mix very
well to do this they are using advanced
cameras attached to a submersible
platform bridge this is camera control
can we drop our speed to one knot please
and we'll take it down to the bottom the
system is carefully dropped a thousand
metres down below the surface
[Music]
it's Carr's job to make sure he stops
the platform yep there's the bottom just
two meters before it reaches the seabed
[Music]
if we get too close to the bottom then
we'll bounce off the bottom as we're
flying along then the challenging task
begins navigating the craggy and on even
terrain of seamounts sea mounts are
mostly remnant volcanoes extinct
volcanoes that are millions of years old
though found throughout the ocean from
the poles to the equator over 99% of
them are unexplored cool scientists have
discovered that sea mounts support
astonishingly diverse and unique
ecosystems and provide food and spawning
grounds to a wide variety of fish and
sea mammals we see a lot of animals
particularly fish we sometimes see
larger fish and I guess most typically
they would be sharks that may move from
sea mount to sea mount today the team is
surveying an area of the ocean floor
that has never been explored before
so we've beyond a thousand in these dark
depths over a thousand metres below the
surface the team is astonished to
discover thriving coral communities
there's a general perception that the
majority of areas between sea mounts
were unsuitable for corals but one of
the surprising things has been just how
many of them supported the same kind of
luxuriant coral reefs
but the team is also visiting parts of
the seabed that have experienced human
contact before to survey areas that have
been damaged by bottom trawling this
method of fishing provides the biggest
annual catch globally but uses vast nets
that can literally scrape marine life
off the ocean floor during bottom
trawling the net makes contact with the
seabed and in places where there are
vulnerable animals such as corals they
can be removed damage to sea mounts here
was first logged by scientists in the
1990s but a marine protected area now
keeps many of them safe from the Nets
those that are protected have now had no
physical impacts from fishing for a
20-year period and that enables us to
estimate any sort of changes including
indications of possible recovery the
first signs are encouraging first seem
to be a very large number of urgent
marine life is returning and nominees
are beginning to grow back on the
damaged areas
but it's what the team can't see that's
more worrying there is little evidence
that damaged coral itself the heartbeat
of ecosystems down here is reforming
that's a good enough look to conclude
there's nothing like there are no signs
that the stony coral matrix is returning
coral itself is still likely to take
many years if not decades to form the
first kind of layer of replacement coral
the data gathered here will form part of
a growing body of evidence helping
scientists evaluate whether damaged
areas will ever properly recover the
results from this trip are vital for the
oceans would be protectors as part of
the wider battle to preserve marine
habitats across the ocean floor and make
the case for more controlled and
sustainable fishing we need to keep
damage to sea mounts from fishing to a
minimum the way of doing that is to
understand more about impacts and use
that information to try and contain the
activities of fishing it's very exciting
to be part of a survey like this
[Music]